so I'm not your keynote but I also help
plan this conference I'm the diversity
and sprints chair and I'm really excited
to announce this particular key now it's
a different format than just a
traditional speech we have I'll bring up
milano lewis and while she's walking up
I'll give you her intro she's the CEO
and co-founder of stem it's a platform
that simplifies payments to musicians
and before that she worked at United
talent agency where she helped social
media creators find funding
opportunities and then I'd also like to
bring it to Sylvia Sylvia will be
interviewing Lana in a sort of fireside
chat Sylvia is the organizer of Pi
ladies in Los Angeles and she's also at
data science so Olivia is one of the
people that particularly helps with
getting all these events going in in
this region
she was Gerardus last year she helped
out a lot in getting the first PI data
going and it worked out so well then now
we have the second one so with that
round of applause for our keynote
speaker and our interviewer thank you
again to everybody to join us today for
PI data LA I'm very excited to share the
stage this morning with mulana Lewis
Milan and I actually go back all the way
back to our undergrad days at UCLA when
we were both in the fashion Club in here
we are sharing the stage at PI data LA
so quite the journey so just to kick us
off I wanted to kind of share with the
audience a little bit of the lay of the
land in in so far is our conversation
this morning so in in today's world of
of data abundance in the digital era
there's there's so there's a wealth of
information out there that said not all
of that information is either clear nor
actionable so I'm really excited for you
to share with us in the audience your
perspective on how you came to found the
company so
dis intermedia and your journey leading
meeting you there as well as your
perspective on the difference between
data transparency and data clarity sure
so if you could maybe just share with
the audience a little bit more about
yourself your background and what led
you to start the company what inspired
you yes definitely so the simple idea
behind stem is in this world where
everyone has the opportunity to publish
content directly to their fans and make
money off of it because of all the
various platforms that emerged how do
they share revenue from that content
right because no content is actually
made independently the notion of a DIY
creator doesn't actually exist there's
always collaborators so with me is like
there's songwriters producers labels
with video there's directors or actors
there's screenwriters etc and so all of
these people technically should be
getting a piece of the revenue and yet
online there's no easy way to
automatically do that and the way I came
to the idea was when I was at United
talent agency so long story short we met
in college I actually dropped out before
my senior year because it was 2008 and I
actually couldn't afford a loan I wasn't
qualified to be able to stay and pay
out-of-state tuition at UCLA I
transferred over from Michigan State and
so the advice I got from someone I was
interning for at the time he was a
manager he said take the year off go
work at a talent agency you're gonna
need to get that experience under your
belt anyways if you want to work in
Hollywood and you'll establish residency
and then you'll graduate so one into the
mailroom at the time was William Morris
Endeavor thought I wanted to represent
screenwriters and directors and quickly
started really analyzing my own personal
consumption and realized that while I
loved movies I spent more time watching
videos on the internet right like spend
more time consuming stories narrative
narratives off of social media of my
friends and that fulfilled me and I
became fascinated with all of the new
talent and IP that was emerging off
these platforms whether it was talent
off of Twitter so people creating
Twitter accounts and generating
content from that and then that
transitioning into movies and TV shows
you now know as well as the YouTube
stars has sort of emerged and wanted to
represent those people and that wasn't
really a job back then like there wasn't
a digital media agent the early 2000s
and like the idea of a vlogger having
some kind of like online stardom is
edits inception and in fact when I went
to the talent agents at Leigh Morris at
the time and I said hey can I be a
coordinator that discovers Talent off
the internet that you guys send in sign
they said were laughed at me and they
said hon that sounds like a really
interesting intern opportunity but not a
job this was like 2009 now and so I
decided to go back to college and
graduated ended up dropping out of the
film program at UCLA and wanted to study
the audience had became obsessed with
how consumption has changed across
various verticals and across various
audiences and so as I was graduating I
got a call from a colleague who I was
consulting with and he said you know I
know you don't want to be a talent agent
but UTA is hiring for digital media
agent and so I took that opportunity
took the interview and ended up taking
the job because what inspired me was the
mandate I was given which was that they
believed that technology was going to
completely change their business but as
talent agents they didn't feel
threatened instead they saw opportunity
for all these platforms to enable their
artists to go more direct to their fans
and find unique ways of telling their
stories and monetizing it and they
wanted me to be the person who could
help figure out how to connect the dots
right so if a client had an idea how do
they bring it to life so it was
everything from Rob Thomas who's the
creator of Veronica Mars thinking about
how do I take Veronica Mars the TV show
make it into a movie and so we ended up
partnering him up with Kickstarter and
ran a whole campaign to raise money for
that independently if you guys are fans
of Veronica Mars and follow that it was
comedians like Dane Cook and Aziz Ansari
deciding to self distribute their comedy
specials instead of posting them or
selling them to HBO been doing it direct
through Twitter so it was about all of
that and my job is to say okay here are
the new platforms that exist in order
for you to be able to do this more
direct to your fans and then also for
focus on how do companies like Netflix
and who they know there's probably a
number of you guys in the room here how
did they figure out what they're looking
to buy and how do we educate the talent
agency internally on how to think about
how they develop properties and sell
them to Netflix and Hulu with their
talent and then the last thing that we
had to figure out was how do we use data
to analyze and predict the success of
our project so one of the projects I was
involved with was how do we use
sentiment analysis with the volume based
off the reaction that fans give when a
movie trailer premieres and how do we
use that to predict box office opening
weekend so my job of sort of across the
board but alongside all of it the
conversations we kept having were with
the talent they would say help me make
more money independently how do I do
that
and given that at the time now we're
talking about 2012 there were all these
different ways that you could distribute
your content right so getting it out
there wasn't the problem
there wasn't a problem about how do you
monetize it because all these services
were starting to turn on monetization
and new platforms we're emerging as well
and it wasn't about how do I find my
fans and how do I sell to them because
we're talking about named talent right
who have brand recognition who know and
have cultivated audiences directly
through social media but the number one
reason why they would hesitate to go
direct to their fans was because there's
no easy way to pay their collaborators
and when you're working with projects at
a high level scale the problem wasn't
just about how do I get it out there and
make money well now that I'm making
money how do i account to everyone else
and so I started looking at the
ecosystem looking at companies that were
solving this and other businesses right
so you have companies like square and
stripe and Braintree that are building
solutions for small to medium sized
businesses and as a personal you know
human there's all these financial tools
that people have access to in order to
manage their money and manage their P&L
their business and I realized that known
as building this for the creative class
and the simple idea that I talked about
the beginning how do you share revenue
on a piece of content was sort of like
the impetus for the whole thought and so
that's really what inspired stem and
what we do today is we decided to focus
on music as the first vertical so we are
one of the top partners in to Spotify
Apple Google
Amazon all the major music streaming
services a number of independent artists
and independent labels people like Frank
OSHA and Keith Urban as well as like
some of the newer artists that if any of
you go to music festivals and you see
them performing from like 2 o'clock to 6
o'clock sort of the emerging guys a lot
of those youth them as well and their
managers to get their music onto the
platforms and then in return once the
music is performing we collect the data
and the revenue and we distribute it not
only to the uploader who's the artist or
the label but we pay out all of the
rights holders at the same time and
we're the only platform that gives every
single person who's involved in the
project a dashboard where they can track
and see the data associated with the
earnings so we report to them on a
monthly basis
it sounds really basic but when we
started in 2015 we were the only company
to do that and the big reason for it is
because you sort of talk about
transparency versus clarity this is a
really big thing we focus on because a
lot of artists have transparency to
their data when they're going
independent but they're overwhelmed by
it and paralyzed and so the big thing we
think about is how do we make data more
clear and so we decided to focus on
aggregating the revenue data and putting
data in dollars because at the end the
day when you're thinking about building
a business you think about how much
money am I making where is it coming
from and how do I continue to reinvest
in myself so that that raises I think a
question in my mind because often times
like when you know a person like me such
as myself I hear the words transparency
and clarity I think of them as
synonymous so how how is it from your
perspective that you delineate the
difference between these ideas of
transparency versus clarity and how is
that how does that play into stemis
overall mission yeah definitely before I
give there's an analogy I'd like to
think about but before I do that how
many of you guys currently work at
companies that service somehow
entertainment whether it's video or
music awesome ok
so when I think about transparency I
think about a story I heard about one of
the most senior executives at the time
who was running a record label today
he's working at one of the major
platforms in a meeting his finance team
shared with him that some of their
biggest artists had requested to audit
the record label for their finances
right you keep hearing stories about
artists feeling like they're getting
screwed I'm not knowing where the money
is that's a consistent narrative in the
business that we operate in
unfortunately and his response to that
request was that's great if they want
the data give it to them but give it to
them in something that's as thick as the
yellow pages so they never asked for it
again
and that's to me transparency it's like
you want data go here you go what are
you gonna do with it right like how are
do you process how do you analyze how do
you act on something that is so dense
and so when we approach it and when we
think about it we think about it in
terms of clarity right because it's our
job to almost be like the data janitors
right how do we collect and aggregate
all of the tremendous data that we get
access to from Spotify Apple Amazon
Google that 25 platforms that we
currently work with and how do we make
it actionable for the unused and what's
been really interesting and challenging
for us is thinking about who that end
user is and what they need to do with
the data because that also is very
different yeah so can you provide some
examples on like maybe certain products
that you offer it stem that actually a
like maybe speak to certain data points
that you track that help provide these
artists driven businesses gain clarity
in order to make better informed
decisions around you know say for
example whether to collaborate or
whether to take the lead on a specific
piece of work that they'd like to
explore further yes definitely so when
we came into the business right this is
2015 so none of the music streaming
service has had artists facing
dashboards at the time actually I
believe that they legally weren't
allowed to share something like
streaming data with artists directly
because this is when they were still
negotiating with all the major labels
and the major labels wanted to
control the power of the data I think
Spotify launched its first artist facing
dashboard in 2016 2017 I think the only
one that kind of existed was the next
big sound which was acquired by Pandora
but otherwise the biggest thing is that
artists had no idea how much money they
were making right and the thing in music
is that the number of streams are
false-positive and they don't
necessarily correlate to revenue because
of all the different variables of how
that revenue is calculated so the first
thing we wanted to answer for artists is
how much money is my content worth right
because if they're gonna be negotiating
deals on behalf of themselves whether
it's with them determining do I stay
independent and do this in my own or do
I sign with a major label they need to
know well how much am I making on my own
and so the first thing we wanted to show
them was just how much revenue are they
making for a song for each song that
they release and then on the
collaborator level if you're a producer
for your songwriter
what's your share worth write what are
your five to ten to twenty percent of
the song worth it sounds really basic to
us but most creators have no idea what
their share of the pie is actually worth
and giving that visibility was
tremendously valuable because now they
can think more strategically about how
do I invest in my growth right so if I'm
a songwriter a producer it's quite
oftentimes I'm thinking about how do I
invest my time do I continue to write
songs for other people or do I want to
make my own music right and there's
always a trade-off you have to think
about and so with stem they can see
great I have 5% of songs when I
producers when I'm a producer on them or
a songwriter on them and if these songs
make a lot of money my 5% could be worth
more than 100% of my own music right and
so how do I think about how I spend my
time that's one piece of it
and we thought that there'd be a lot
more intelligence and actionable
insights to gain from looking at how
much revenue each platform drives but
that was also interesting to find out
that it's like great you know how much
money you make more on Spotify versus
Apple but what are you gonna do about
that right like when you're not gonna
put your music on one of the platforms
are you gonna promote one over the other
like not really helpful yeah so on that
in that vein can you speak to maybe some
more of the consultative liked or
consultative excuse me services that
stung
providing currently to the artists
business yeah so this year we made a
really hard tricked decision to our
business we launched something called
stem direct and when we started stem we
have always been invite-only and we grew
user based that included a big part of
the DIY segment right and one thing we
learned is that the pain points and the
needs of giy artists are very different
than artists who are career artists
versus hobbyist and artists who have
management teams behind them or
independent labels the types of data
they care about the things that they're
looking for as lovers to grow their
business are very different and as many
of you know if you're working at a
startup the number one thing that kills
a startup is lack of focus and so we had
to make a really hard choice to focus
and double down on a segment that we
knew we could super serve that everyone
else was under serving and so with that
we launched dumb direct and with stem
direct it's both the platform and the
tools plus each artist and their
management team have a dedicated Account
Manager in stem and the reason for that
is twofold Wine the process of content
distribution requires a little bit of
hand-holding because there's a strategy
component to it but number two is
because most artists and their
management teams actually don't know how
to analyze the data and so after they
put out a release even then we give them
a dashboard of insights of how that
release is doing both in terms of
financial data and now more recently
trending data they don't know what to do
with it and so we realized that the way
we can help them learn how to drive
value is instead of like doing the work
for them like a record label does its
how do we teach them to analyze the data
right so a lot of our account management
team right now is serving kind of like
lightweight data analysts where they're
helping to support the artists by
looking into their data and one thing we
continue to sort of debate internally is
how much do we invest in building some
of these views in these tools inside the
dashboard and what we decided
strategically for the short term is
honestly let's aggregate the data and
build custom reports because every
artist what we're seeing is that they
have different things they want to see
and once we realize that we start trying
to
similar types of reports over and over
again but we'll actually invest in
building it into the dashboard but when
you give artists and their teams too
much modularity within the dashboard to
create their own views they won't do it
like they don't have they don't know
what answers are looking what they don't
know what questions are looking to
answer and therefore they don't know
what used to build right so that kind of
like you don't want to lead them down
back to the path of like how you're
thinking about transparency and just
kind of yeah you keep paralyzed them
because you give them too many options
and all these analysis analysis
paralysis exactly yeah
well that's great so can you I would
imagine that like as you continue to
grow the business another challenge that
you have in addition to going with a
product like stem direct and choosing to
move forward in that direction in terms
of product decisions like how what other
challenges do you face and how do you
use data internally to to address those
yeah we actually think about it we put
ourselves in the shoes of our users
quite a bit right and one thing that
we've realized is that as a startup
there's a couple of core metrics you
absolutely need to know right you need
to understand where you're getting your
users from how much they're worth what
the cost of acquisition is what your
churn rates look like and these are
basic business functions that artists
need to know too so as we learn how to
analyze them for ourselves we're just an
aggregator right but are the same
questions that we ask ourselves are the
same questions that some of our users
ask who are music managers or who are
labels because they're aggregating
talent as well in assets and they need
to analyze these things they want to
know what's the value of their catalogue
what's their cost of acquiring a fan or
listener how much is their catalog worth
what's the lifetime value of a release
what's the decay rate right so we're
analyzing it internally and externally
at the same time which has been really
interesting but the hardest metric for
us to measure has been turned and this
is sort of going into some of the
nuisances of the business that we're in
so we have our artists fall into
generally two buckets those buckets are
big established names people like Keith
Urban who are legacy artists that are
and decided to be independent right or
their emerging artists who are just
starting their careers in which case
there's a lot of growth opportunity for
them with every new release they gain an
audience that release grows their fan
base and their general catalog grows as
well and one of the businesses almost 5
years old will be 5 in April but the
typical new artist career really takes 3
to 4 years to take off and about a year
ago we started seeing tremendous amount
of churn we couldn't measure turn the
right way because we experienced hard
churn and soft churn so what's yeah
what's the difference to you sure
so hard churn is much easier to define
that's when a user or an artist uploads
content to stem and then for one reason
or another they remove it from stem and
move it to a different platform that
could happen because the artist gets
signed to a major record label and they
have to remove all of their copyrights
over away from being independent system
over to that major label or because they
decide that they want to take the music
down they don't like it they want to
change the direction of the sound
they're going in there's multiple
reasons right soft turn is actually much
harder to measure soft churn is when an
artist releases a number of things
through stem and then decides to use a
record label or another distributor for
their next project but they keep their
music on stem and the reason that's hard
to measure is because oftentimes their
revenue keeps growing even though
they're not releasing new content in the
platform and so with some artists like
Scheck Wes is a really great example if
you guys follow hip hop at all but we
had Shaq West's Mambo really early on in
the stem system and then he signed with
a major record label put out an album
that tracks sort of going like this but
we don't have his business anymore so
how do you measure turn when you see
like significant artists growth off of
an upload and you're not getting any
future releases right so that's been
really challenging for us it's also
exciting but it's it makes looking at
LTV even more challenging right because
if they keep their assets in the system
the lifetime value keeps growing of the
user even though there's no
cost to serve so our metrics as an
Operations business like looking at the
operational unit metrics of our business
is kind of funky well that sounds like
something that you're gonna be
continuing to explore with your team so
that's I think I think overall and in
the industry like it's just I think the
business that you started I I commend
you because it has to be drawn from
inspiration given all the nuance and
challenges of the ecosystem itself and
kind of the vast range of everyone from
small and emerging independent artists
to well-known names so with that said
like is there anything else that like
you'd like to share with the audience
and so far as like any additional
insights that you've gained and say
maybe it's just the last year in the
most recent year that you've grown as a
business yeah definitely I think the one
thing we think a lot about here and I
imagine you guys are thinking about this
as well from your various jobs is how do
you use data to predict growth right and
we look at it in a couple of different
ways so on one hand we put ourselves in
the shoes of an artist and we say okay
what are the things that they think
about that they believe to be lovers and
growing your business and right now one
of the unfortunate things and you
probably know a lot about this is
playlist and curation right the curation
algorithms that many of the platforms
have developed are intended to drive
diversity of consumption across the
platform right
and it's been interesting to see how it
evolved from being human creation to
algorithmic back to human and now
they're sort of struggling to figure out
which direction they go because it needs
to be there needs to be an element of
human curation to some extent and so
artists care about how do I get my song
playlisted right any of you guys use
Spotify or Apple and discover your music
through playlists or release radar great
so if I'm an artist all I'm thinking
about is how do I get my music in front
of you and you open up the app right and
there's so many new senses to it and one
of the things that we're trying to
figure out is how do we hack the
- or help our artists hack the algorithm
in order to get recognition and the
answer is just put yourself in the shoes
of the fan right that's not the only
answer but it's a big one because at the
end of the day what you guys are
thinking about is what are these passion
indicators right well we're thinking
about what is the reaction score that
you guys are analyzing to figure out how
to recommend something and so a lot of
the time that we're spending right now
is thinking through that right so we
spent we spent so much time analyzing
all of the API points that we have
available to us and then we realized
like oh you know what maybe let's not
think about what can we build based on
the data we have available let's think
about it from what I said earlier which
is what does a fan do when they discover
a new music right so you open up your
app you put a playlist on you hear a
song you like what's the action you take
you probably like the song or you click
through to see who the artist is read
more about them maybe you share it right
these are all passion indicators and so
what we think about a lot now is well
how are they weighed right and how do we
surface that data to a user so that they
can drive insights from it because if
they get added to new music Fridays
right what's the call to action how do
they monetize not- has how to maximize
that opportunity gives them an initial
spike but what can they do do they
instead of tweeting their song out to
their fans so we say add it to a
playlist right how do they drive more
interactivity that drive some of these
passion indicators so that their song
has more reaction right which ultimately
does tie back to I think an artist and
goal in terms of driving more revenue to
their overall business and again another
way of like helping them inform their
decision making on how how to create
like have you gotten feedback from any
of your customers and so far as like the
services that you provide and how it
influenced maybe some of their decision
making can you provide an example yeah
there's been tons of that I'll talk
about in a second but the one thing I
want to add is that there is a huge
delay and lag in connecting the data
between the trending metrics that I'm
talking about right because we have
daily data analytics we pull that give
us these insights around
sort of where the streams are coming
from how many user-generated playlists
ads how many favorites how many likes
are happening from the songs and who the
customers are they're doing it nothing
who the customers are about how many of
them are there right like sort of the
volume metrics around that and we don't
get financial data until net 60 that 90
days right so even though you see the
trending data analytics you can't
connect that to revenue right away and
that's one of the problems that we'd
love to solve but it'll be a while until
we can get there but in terms of some of
the insights and problems we've been
able to solve for users there's a couple
of sort of funny stories so one thing
that's become really interesting is that
the types of people who are added as
shareholders in stem have changed it's
not what we thought it was initially we
thought it would be your creators like
your collaborators the people who you
work with to make the music your
songwriters your producers maybe your
label what we're seeing now is more and
more people who help support and service
the content are being added in share as
shareholders so the marketing person the
social media coordinator if an artist
decides to hire a radio promo person to
work the record at radio they give them
a piece of the back and add them as a
shareholder and then more recently we're
starting to see artists add in investors
and so what they're doing is they're
saying hey my music and my assets are
generating this much money per month I
need money for my next project I'm gonna
go to my friends and family and I can
show them my stem dashboard to show them
exactly how much money I'm making and
then I can add them in as a shareholder
and they'll get paid directly and the
way we realized this is because in
support in our support threads we had
users coming to us saying hey can I add
someone as a shareholder and changed the
contract and we started seeing that more
and more and so we started asking the
question well why who are these people
and they were added as a role of other
and we just reached out to a couple
users and we found out that a number of
them were seeking independent investors
and friends and family and we're
enabling them to recoup directly in the
application and so now we're thinking
about okay how do we facilitate that
experience more seamlessly and with less
friction so that's one side of it the
other one is more interesting so some of
our many of our users I should say not
some are based in Atlanta we're pretty
heavy in the hip hop
urban genre and we started seeing icebox
as a shareholder Danny do you know who
that is
probably not icebox is a jewelry store
in Atlanta and I called my director of
new business who focuses on Atlanta and
I said Jason why are they a shareholder
did they start a record label like
what's going on and he's like you know
get this some of our rappers have
layaway fees that they're using stem to
pay back so it's been really interesting
what our users are using when we enable
you to share revenue with anyone and I
don't know how much data insights they
care about on the music consumption I
think they just care about being able to
track how much money they're getting
paid back but I think it's amazing that
we're able to drive a level of
visibility that informs an artist on how
they can be smarter about their business
wow sounds like stems kind of expanding
into the whole of like the artists
businesses PNL not just like direct
expenses regarding to collaborators or
producers but other aspects of things
that they may consider expenses to
manage their like brand image and so on
like icebox well and that's absolutely
true right like our mission at the end
of the day is how do we enable creators
to build sustainable businesses and the
thing that we believe prevents them from
doing so today is that they simply don't
have visibility into their finances and
so when you turn the lights on for it
them and they can see how much money
they're making where it's coming from
and track how they're investing in it in
their content across that they can be
smarter about their business right and
they don't go yeah and they don't have
to make really poor decisions about how
they invest in themselves right
oftentimes they end up taking really
unfortunate deals from whether it's
major labels or other sources of capital
because they can't go to a bank and say
hey give me a small business loan and
most banks don't understand how to
credit an artist right how do you value
their music or their assets when it's
inconsistent and I think that for us is
one of the biggest and most exciting
opportunities to think through is given
the data that we have in
given the knowledge that we have about
all the nuisances that impact the
financial picture of a creators career
in business how do we help them gain
access to not only financial tools but
financial services because at the end of
the day that's what drives our
sustainability right every business
needs a way to sustain itself through
access to capital whether it's through
revenue growth or through investment
yeah it's a very nuanced area I mean my
background prior to data science having
worked in in credit and loans it's not
that kind of P&L and balance sheet is
not something that's like easily
underwritten or anything that there's
like a formulaic way of evaluating
credit for so it's really interesting
work that you're trying to provide so in
terms of of stem supporting artists
businesses in some ways I almost think
of stem as like tangential if not
touching on like a thin tech company
yeah I mean that's we'd love to be I'll
be honest like we're far from that still
but that's definitely the direction we
want to go in I think that there's so
many tools that we as the general public
have at our disposal to manage our money
today that very specific segments of the
rest of the population lack for their
business and if we can solve that for
the creative population everything from
financial tools to small to small to
medium-sized business tools around
accounting revenue management basic data
insights I think we can really move the
needle and disrupt the business in a way
that hasn't been possible before because
for the most part if you were an artist
you needed to sign away to a major
record label and hope that there was
someone there that was going to push
your business and then pray to God you'd
see the money from it beyond the initial
advance and times have definitely
changed and what we're seeing is this
unbundling of the major label business
where more and more artists are choosing
to be independent because they can be
and they are taking their business into
their control they're hiring the teams
of people
to work for them directly versus relying
on a big one-stop shop and so a lot of
the questions that they don't have to
worry about answering before because the
major label would have the
infrastructure and the people in-house
to do it for them now it's on them and
their management team to figure out and
so how do we build tools that give them
the ability to simplify that but give
them the power and the intelligence to
really grow that's great I think this is
a good place to open it up for questions
from the audience if there are any
there's one back there hi your your
point about you know how can you help
artists sort of maximize their music for
the Spotify algorithm you know it kind
of just feels like the new wave of like
search engine optimization except now
the search engine is Spotify or
SoundCloud or wherever you get your
music from so I was kind of curious if
you've already sort of seen some some of
the ways that this is affected how music
has been developed because you're
optimizing it for Spotify and I know I
recently watched a segment on Hasan
Minhaj a show where he talked about how
hip-hop now it's it's like these
two-minute tracks cuz you're optimizing
for number of plays on Spotify because
that's how you make money so I was
curious if you've seen any sort of other
trends similar to what has been seen in
hip-hop yeah we talked about this quite
a bit and I talked about it a lot with
some of the songwriters and producers
who've been in the business for decades
right and the new you if you start
listening to music you pay attention
notice this you have 15 seconds to grab
the attention so even the way a song is
structured we're seeing people move the
hook up into the first twenty seconds of
a song because a lot of discovery is
driven through playlists and with things
like new music Friday and release radar
they're not cohesive playlists right
they'll mix genres from artists you
follow and so you might have a downtempo
mic melodic track and then followed
right after by a big indie pop hit
followed by country
followed by R&B depending on how diverse
your listening taste is right and so
that doesn't really flow and so it
interrupts the experience and for user a
lot of them skip the song if they don't
like it so how do you maximize that
that's one thing the other thing that
I've noticed quite a bit as peoples
people don't give songs a chance anymore
right like there's this chicken and egg
scenario between the streaming world and
the radio world right it used to be that
you need a radio to break as an artist
and then streaming came along and it's
like no anyone can break through
streaming right you can discover your
fan base through SoundCloud or through
Google or through Spotify and so to sort
of touch on your question about SEO it's
so different by platform right so
YouTube is purely SEO driven a lot of it
right there's a bit of human creation
but you'll get things recommended based
on features so in keywords right so if
you're a young artist and you're
featured on a chance the rapper song
you're likely to get discovered and your
music is likely to get hurt because it's
going to be the next song after someone
decides to listen to chance doesn't
necessarily work that way on Spotify nor
does it work their way at an apple and
so we have to think about well what is
driving these algorithms because the
sort of SEO nature of it's a very
different perform which is also one of
the challenges about how we decide to
give insights to artists because it
depends on per platform like what
metrics matter and what data points
matter but going back to what sort of
the other part of it is is the radio and
streaming world now radio wants to see
how the song is doing in streaming right
so how did the song perform after after
its first week and if it doesn't get the
reaction in the first week that song may
not have a life and that is so sad
because music needs to be heard over and
over again in various contexts to
resonate I'm I hope many of you can sort
of relate to that how many times have
you heard a song and it took you until
like the 10th or 20th time to hear to
Big O actually like you're right like
there's so much music you hear and
you're like I don't like that right away
you want to skip it but then somehow you
keep hearing it and it starts resonating
it's so contextual and I'm concerned
that the context out of music discovery
and artist discovery is at stake given
how much focus there
on the curation element in the
reactivity I had a question it's more on
the soft skills side of things I work at
a law firm so one of our biggest
challenges is trying to convince our
users that what we're doing from a data
perspective is beneficial for them I
could see a lot of that probably being
the same challenges that you have how do
you go about tackling it can you drill
in a little bit more so I can answer it
more specifically sure for example we
are doing a climber attention project on
a law firm side and we can predict let's
say very high accuracy whether or not a
client is going to leave us or not
pitching that to stake holder is a
little bit difficult because even if
let's say you have 80% accuracy on your
prediction they see a very big company
about to leave you that you're
inaccurate about they want to throw the
entire project away or maybe they're not
as apt to listen so I imagine from your
perspective trying to convince artists
or just anybody to join your platform
because now they have access to data how
do you convince them that this platform
is beneficial for them
it's that's why we didn't start just as
a data analytics platform right we went
straight to the money everyone wants to
get paid got it and so that was our hook
if we can make it easier for you not to
have to chase money as a shareholder
you're gonna create a network effect
that's gonna drive more users right so
our biggest growth vertical that
vertical bottom lever has been the fact
that early on if you're uploading a song
you add shareholders those shareholders
get invited to stem they convert to get
paid and most of the time they're
songwriters and producers right these
people are sort of nodes in the network
they collaborate with tons of an artists
throughout even a week like a typical
songwriter producer will sit with five
or seven artists in a weekly basis out
of maybe 150 songs they produce a dozen
of them make it out into the real world
maybe even last these are sort of
high-level metrics that I'm making up on
the spot but our biggest conversion
funneled was through just collaborators
it was shareholders who had a great
experience got paid quickly and if
you're a shareholder in you're
collaborating in the next project and
that artist is independent you have an
opportunity to influence what platform
they use to distribute their music
you're gonna recommend
and so we started seeing a lot of growth
through the network through
collaborators converting but what's
funny about the music business is some
artists don't want to deal with the data
right and so at any given moment we
always in meetings ask about what is the
ratio look like and so we think about
this like pie chart right and we think
about how big is the slice that's going
to be representing the decision based on
data like how much of its data informed
and how much of its FOMO and most of the
time when we have these conversations
with people we've realized that the data
inform piece unfortunately represents
maybe like 20 to 25% of the picture and
the rest of it is film oh okay any plans
for expanding to writers to screen
writers or writers book writers oh my
god I'd love to oh I mean the big vision
is to really build this for the creative
class right so not just musicians I
think music for us was the first
vertical I don't know which one the
second one is next to be honest it could
but the verticals we really look at for
the future involve everything from I
think a publishing was really exciting
writers not only in terms of authoring
books but writers who are contributors
to publications right and our freelance
workers and work across multiple
platforms I think there's a huge
opportunity for these publishers to
offer revenue share on a per article
basis based on the way it's performing I
feel like that's gonna be a future and
so if that exists would be great to
simplify how those publishing companies
pay out their shareholders or their
collaborators and their contributors we
look at key gaming a lot that's an
exciting space that is also one that
just lacks a tremendous amounts of
transparency the gamers who play for
some of the league's wine the waterfall
of when they get paid is so delayed and
there's so many middlemen as well but
there's also such lack and transparency
and reporting there we're in video today
so we can share revenue off a YouTube
video I think that as since we're in
this room hopefully someday Netflix and
Hulu
sher consumption data with the rights
owners and maybe even payout on the back
end and if that happens I'd love to get
into long-form video and then I think
ecommerce is really big too if you think
about all of the independent store funds
that exist with the small brands that
are growing quickly on platforms like
Shopify and how they're collaborating
with each other and how they probably
have multiple people they need to pay
royalties to whether it's designers or
manufacturers so I think there's a lot
of opportunity there so I was wondering
if you currently have a function for
trading those shares because if you
allow for shirts to be traded and
eventually to have some sort of market
there's a lot of information that you
can then gather from that trading
information to use for your predictions
right yeah we so there's a couple of
companies that are currently doing this
right there's companies like vest their
song trader there's royalty exchange
they're companies that allow a
shareholder to sell their shares and
songs and it's more of a marketplace
function we decided that that's not the
route we want to go in I think that it's
definitely an opportunity but what we
are more interested in right now is
having that person understand the value
of their shares and if they want to
trade it independently they can but
there's a couple of announcements that
we're gonna make in the beginning of the
year that'll give you more insight into
the direction we're heading and when it
comes to how do you access capital as a
shareholder great thanks are you going
to be able to stick around to answer a
few more questions if the audience has
any yeah definitely awesome well thank
you so much again for your time and for
joining us here at high data LA and for
sharing your insights in perspective
it's been really interesting to hear
about what inspired you to start stem
and stem journey so with that if the
audience could join me in thanking
mallanna once more thank you thank you
all
you